Love is potentially the most intensely thought about thing in all of human history...
...and despite centuries upon centuries of obsession, it still overwhelms us.
Some say it's a feeling, a magical emotion,...
...a feeling for someone like you've never felt before.
But feelings are fluid, not very concrete foundation for a definition.
Sometimes, you hate the person you love.
Plus, come on, you've felt feelings like it before, sort of in miniature.
Your relationships with your family shape your relationships with partners...
...and your love for your partner may be in its own dynamic relationship,...
...healthy or totally weird,...
...with the love of your parents and siblings.
Love is also a set of behaviors we associate with the feeling:...
...holding hands, kissing, hugging, public displays of affection,...
...dating, marriage, having kids or just sex,...
...but these loving actions can be subjective or culturally relative.